okay so let's talk about attention and
consciousness so what is attention
attention is about doing computation in
a focused way we're gonna sequentially
focus computation on one or a few
elements at a time and we realized in
around 2014 that this was extremely
powerful and and was the reason why we
were able to get a breakthrough in
machine translation when you when you
produce the next word in English when
you're trying to translate from French
say you want to really focus the
computation on just the right few words
in in the French sentence that are
relevant to do the translation so we
introduced a particular form of
attention called content-based soft
attention which is very convenient
because you can backdrop through it and
so you can learn it in other words we
can learn where to attend and so the way
it works is the computation being done
at the next level is going to use this
input a selection from the previous
level of computation and that selection
is going to be a soft selection so we're
going to take a convex weighted
combination of value vectors from the
previous level and these convex weights
are coming from through a soft max that
is conditioned on each of the elements
so for each of the elements we're going
to see how well they match the context
to see you on which one the attention
should be focused so in a way attention
is peril right we're we're considering
all the possible elements in some set
and we're computing a score for each of
them in order to decide on which one or
which ones we're going to put attention
and there's been recent work in
cognitive neuroscience throwing that
attention should be thought of as a as
an internal action right so the way that
your brain is is atending is very
similar to the way that your motor
system is deciding to move your arm and
so we want to learn these attention
policies so attention has been very very
useful
I mentioned machine translation but
essentially today's NLP systems
state-of-the-art systems all rely on
attention
look at the older work based on
transformers and their variations
they're also the heart of memory
extended neural nets we had a paper last
year and more ongoing work on how
attention connected to memory can also
unlock the problem of vanishing
gradients and as I'll mention attention
also allows to change your nets from
machines that are processing vectors to
machines that are processing sets and in
particular sets of key value pairs okay
so so let's see this picture again we
can think of attention as creating a
dynamic connection between two layers
whereas in a traditional setting the
connections are fixed here we kind of
pick which of the inputs is going to be
sent to the whatever module we're
considering that uses an attention
mechanism now this is great but from the
point of view of the receiving module
there is a problem it gets this value
which is one of those in the sets of the
set of input elements but it doesn't
know where it's coming from right it's
the value of what and so what we're
doing it with attention mechanisms is in
addition to the value we have some
concept of key in other words an kind of
identifier for where the value coming is
coming from currently reusing those keys
to decide which element should get the
attention but that key is also sent to
the next level and so downstream
computation can know what the value it's
getting is is what it is what it's
coming from what kind of object it is
what kind of type it is so you can think
of this as creating a name for these
these objects and creating a form of
indirection and and and as I said now we
have these systems of operating on sets
why is it a set because the attention
mechanism doesn't care of the order in
which we're putting these these elements
in the first layer it just you know
picks one according to how well it
matches the some some kind of learned
policy but the information about the
relative position of these elements in
it say in your brain or in a new
the architecture it doesn't matter
anymore okay now let's connect to what
our friends in neuroscience and
cognitive science are doing in our
community the the C word consciousness
is still kind of taboo but but in their
community it's not anymore and that's
great they've made a lot of progress in
understanding several aspects of
consciousness and there are a number of
theories but many of them are related to
what's called the global work space
theory which originated from bars and
there's a lot of very good important
improvements to it from standing on and
collaborators and what this theory says
is that what's going on with with
consciousness is there's a bottleneck of
information the some some elements of
what is computed in your brain gets
selected and then broadcast to the rest
of the brain and influencing the rest of
the brain so this is related to
short-term memory where the things that
have been selected are available and
conditions heavily perception and action
so it also gives rise naturally to the
kind of system to abilities that I've
been talking about alright so how is
machine learning going to do something I
mean what's the connection with machine
learning machine learning could be used
to help brain sciences better understand
consciousness but but what we are
understanding of consciousness could
also help machine learning develop
better abilities so first of all the
work that's been done in neuroscience in
general is based on fairly qualitative
descriptions of these functionalities
that we we think associated with
consciousness and what machine learning
can do is help us formalize in in a way
that's you know more mechanistic what
would these exactly means and and then
that could feed back the the research in
in neuroscience in order to provide
specific more specific tests that could
be could be done of these theories of
course
for me at least one of the motivations
is also to get rid of the sort of fuzzy
force enos and magic that that surrounds
the word consciousness and and and I
think machine learning is in a good
position to provide a justification for
these particular forms of computations
in a sense of you know why do they why
have they evolved what kind of
computational and statistical advantage
are coming with these particular forms
of computations and of course once we
understand these things we also want
them in our learning agents so
consciousness is is closely related to
language because the way that we know
that somebody is conscious is by asking
them to report what they're thinking
about so this is the direct way that we
know about consciousness and that means
that there's a very strong link between
your thoughts that you know things of
you're conscious of and language that
one can be translated to the other
fairly easily over the loss of
information when you go from your
thoughts to to language it also means
that there's a connection between system
1 and system 2 here because those
high-level concepts that we communicate
with language are anchored in the system
one sort of intuitive system that
connects your brain to the rest of the
world through through perception and
action and and I think that's one of the
big important direction for natural
language research we really want to
explore things like grounded language
learning where we don't just learn from
texts we learn from environments which
involves perception action the the
perception action loop through the
environment and and allow a learner not
just to get to the patterns of sequence
of words but but also what they referred
to is as its understanding potentially
implicit of how the world works and I
refer you here to some work we've we've
done recently in publish to the last I
clear on grounded language learning
something that I
baby AI